le festival et hall aura bien lieu du 10
au 12 septembre prochain sur l'île
l'aumône de mantes la jolie pour la
troisième édition des festivités le
principe reste le même ce festival
présente la particularité d'être
l'occasion de la mise en valeur de la
facture instrumentale des manufactures
d'instruments de musique à vent qui sont
situées sur le territoire et plus
précisément à mantes la ville
on a aujourd'hui deux leaders mondiaux
qui sont dans le mantois qui fabrique
des instruments de musique donc pouvoir
porter un événement culturel de
dimension nationale qu'ils fassent un
clin d'oeil à cette identité c'est
évidemment une satisfaction particulière
ainsi la programmation fait en sorte
qu'un instrument à vent soit sur scène
pour chaque concert et des concerts il y
en aura plus de 20 avec certains visages
connus du grand public
en ce qui concerne les têtes d'affiché
va nous avons le vendredi me
principalement kassav
nous avons le samedi rhoda scott et les
avaient entourées d'un orchestre féminin
et le dimanche debout sur le zinc et
thomas dutronc
[Musique]
cette année bon ils tous les artistes
demandent qu'à jouer
c'est relativement facile de les faire
venir il envie de jouer ils connaissent
le lieu est tous croisent pour le mieux
les incertitudes liées à la coved qui
n'influe pas sur la programmation mais
plutôt sur l'organisation
on part sur un festival qui a une jauge
inférieur à 1000 personnes
et donc voilà on reste dans ce cadre qui
elle qui est établie aujourd'hui on a
anticipé beaucoup de choses donc l'idée
c'est que ça joue on est quand même dans
des métiers qui on sait s'adapter en est
réactif et on le fera si on doit
s'adapter dans un sens ou dans un autre
en tout cas l'idée c'est que ça joue au
moins deux des tarifs pour les places
varie entre 25 et 33 euros pour un jour
des pass 3 jours sont également en vente
à 62 euros d'abord en quantité limitée
puis 78 euros